Let's now talk about DNS security. To understand the threats and vulnerabilities
of DNS, let's take a look at the DNS architecture. So we have a stub resolver
which issues a query to a caching resolver. At this point, we could have
a man in the middle attack, or an attacker which observes a query and forges
a response. If a query goes further than the local caching resolver, say
for example, to an authoritative name server, an attacker could try to send a
reply back to that caching resolver before the real reply comes back to try to
poison, or corrupt, the cache with bogus DNS records for a particular name.
This attack is particularly virulent and we will
look at a cache poisoning attack in this
lecture. Masters and slaves can both be spoofed.
Zone files could be corrupted. Updates to the
dynamic update system could also be spoofed. We
will look at some defenses to cache poisoning,
including the OX20 defense, as well as DNSSEC,
which can protect against some of these spoofing and
man in the middle attacks. In addition to
these attacks, we'll look at an attack called
DNS reflection where the DNS can be used
to mount a large distributed denial of service attack.